have you ever wondered how someone
becomes a u.s citizen if they're not
born in the united states attorney eric
palacios from eric colossios and
associates the sponsors of this segment
tells us four ways to gain american
citizenship take a look
hi i'm eric palacios and welcome to the
legal minute the question for today is
what are the four ways to gain american
citizenship the first three are pretty
common number one birth in the usa
number two
acquisition
this is if you were born outside of the
u.s or one of its territories but at
least one of your parents is a citizen
of the united states number three
derivation if your parents become
citizens and you are under the age of 18
you will automatically become a citizen
without an additional application and
number four the one we think about and
the one where you most likely need an
attorney naturalization this is a
specific process and application that
you have to complete generally after
three or five years of being a legal
resident in the united states
thank you for joining us on the legal
minute don't forget to download my free
app eric palacio's legal app and we'll
see you next time
and you can get more information by
going to
ericpalaciosandassociates.com or calling
that phone number 702-444-7777
[Music]